first of all i really enjoyed monday and
i thought you were great in it i put on
twitter that i was going to talk to you
and a lot of people wanted to ask
questions but i think i found one that
is worth
um asking you it comes from a guy named
paul hauser
it is um what is the next movie he and i
will be doing
of mice and men remake or the rich flair
arn anderson biopic
that's it man we gotta do that wrist
player and the sapphire thing
uh you know by the way did you ever you
you have to have interviewed him at some
point right
i'm friendly with paul he's so funny i
mean and he's such a big wrestling
you know fan and i was a big wrestling
fan too growing up like i love wwf
and stuff so and we both have a kickoff
so maybe ric flair
i would do that in a second if they let
me i mean pretty soon you know
i'll be i'll be eligible i guess
after you see oscar isaac dancing in ex
machina
do you sort of get nervous about dancing
in any movie because you have to
ultimately i'm going to compare you to
that by the way
it's so funny you say that like about
that scene because that scene is so
great in ex machina it's like the
weirdest thing right because like
it's clearly a choreographed like piece
in the movie
but for some reason it just like it
sticks out in such a good way and
look i have no qualms about about um
because by the way that's
that song is one of my favorite songs
ever get down saturday night like
it gets played at least once every
saturday you know
um but yeah look i mean we you know it's
uh this was definitely not a
choreographed dancing movie i mean
we were having real parties and um you
know our director
was inviting half of athens to to these
parties and filming them
and and you know we were just in for the
ride which was what the movie was from
the beginning it was like this weird
invitation to go hey like do you want to
go with like
three people you know you you you're on
these sets with hundreds of people
you know all the time and and then what
about like going
and and working with three people like
creating this very intimate movie on
this on this journey and
seeing what happens and you know like
a lot of truth came out of it for us and
yeah
i don't know that that's just how it
ended up yeah
i found um it just felt very real when i
was watching it and it reminded me it's
not the same movie as before sunrise
but it exists in that same kind of world
where you know it's
real people real relationship authentic
honest yeah definitely and you know like
look i think
you know we grow up and we have all
these projections
that we that you know we throw on the
people we meet you know just like
especially you know the the when we're
when we when we
get attracted to somebody you know you
like you immediately sort of like put
your best version forward
and and they do the same and then you
know like a few months in you kind of
like
get to know each other a little bit more
and you're like [ __ ] this is who i'm
with you know and so
i i guess the move like i like that the
movie wasn't afraid of that and then
you know our gary's uh actually he had
two friends
who met at a party and then they ended
up
sleeping on a beach and then the next
morning they
got handcuffed sent to a police station
and that's how they met
and he was like i want to know where
that story goes you know
and i i think for me it's like i've
always loved movies like when harem and
sally and stuff you know
and i love i love like the crescendo of
that ending and but i'm always wondering
like okay
that was new year's eve hell of a way to
go out but like what happens january 1st
you know what happens
february 22nd you know like
when we when we're in that mess you know
and the movie does a great job of
starting with the honeymoon and then
portraying what what is this
relationship but
listen i have to ask you out of all the
roles i've seen you do
this is the one that i'm like like when
you read this script were you like wait
i'm gonna have to
be doing this and then i'm gonna be up
naked on a moped like
there is some crazy stuff that you're
asked to do
were you at any point like i don't know
if i can do this
yeah i mean i think that happened more
like you know
and when we were when we were shooting
the movie like i was i was
halfway through i'm like what where
where am i
like what what what are we doing you
know but but that was because
i think the the process of how we shot
the movie and how we rehearsed it was so
unlike everything else it was you know
it was all very much
uh denise and our gears and i like
spending time together and talking about
things and
things that have happened to each of us
and coming together and
and making sure that you know even that
scene at the end feels
earned in the way and it's not like well
let's just do it to be like whatever
you know that it was you know earned in
some way but i did say i was like i
guess
you know if i'm gonna be naked maybe
in athens on a moped will
have to be it you know like i don't know
but but um and also like
i'm eastern european like at heart you
know like going to greece
and like the people and being in europe
and the mentality over there and
which was very much a part making this
movie of of
of being in the moment and really like
living in the moment is something that
we
do not know as much here in you know
in the states it's completely completely
different energy
yeah for sure completely i am curious so
i'm watching the movie last night
and all i wanted to do is get on a plane
and go to uh greece
so my question is are you getting a
piece of all the people that are going
to fly to greece like all the the money
that's coming in because of watching
this movie
oh no oh man i mean i don't know i mean
the pandemic no i don't know who's
gonna get to greece but like i wish that
i could go
to uh greece tomorrow i would even live
there to be honest for
i don't know like for periods of time i
it just i loved it that much
um but it but there's all these
unexplored islands and there's like i
said there's uh
there's something there about i don't
coming
look coming out of this past year where
we've been so
you know unable to kind of like you know
watching even a party scene like
watching this movie now even i was like
oh my god this looks like a period movie
like how the [ __ ] do we
how are we gonna ever get back to that
like being around each other like that
and being able to be free like that and
you know i think i think that we can't
forget that that's
you know part of our history i guess as
well
that but also to not take advantage of
or take for granted you know
the people in your life that that you
are close to and
that you can be close to you know
completely listen before i run out of
time with you
obviously i i'm going to ask you a
marvel question because
yeah i'm me but i i am it's like a
two-parter and it's not going to get you
in trouble
uh one of the things are you liking the
show
yeah dude listen i'm i'm i'm [ __ ] all
in but i've only seen
i've only seen the first third of it
like this is like a big thing that i've
seen two episodes of
so i'm so i've only seen the first two
this
friday's episode three where i'm going
with this is
one of the things that i'm so blown away
by is kevin feige and his ability to
constantly reinvent what marvel is and
what this mcu is and i'm just curious if
you could talk about
why is kevin feige such a [ __ ]
awesome producer
and part two is um have you guys talked
about
because he kevin told me that he's
talked about doing some
season twos of certain shows have you
talked about doing a second season
of falcon and winter soldier no we have
not and i i'll tell you that honestly we
have not
um uh i have i have no i as
as per usual i don't i don't quite know
what the next step
is you know like we never really do and
and
maybe some people do you know like again
maybe like i
maybe downey used to know i don't know
but like at this point in my life like
11 years into it i don't even you know i
i i got on the phone with him and you
know just to
catch up and and we were saying i was
saying to him i was like dude
you could [ __ ] tell me to go swim
under you know i don't know like
like you could i'll do anything like it
doesn't it doesn't matter
or you know or if or or if this is it
like my heart is just as big you know
like i i have nothing but complete utter
gratitude for
for the opportunities that that i've
gotten from him and especially just
also that anthony and i have gotten now
at the show you know
again my on my end to yet again reinvent
this character find new
nuances about him so it's already kind
of
a win in so many ways you know for me
and second of all
you know i i was like i i asked him i
was like hey don't you like
how do you feel like when you want to
direct one of something one day or
something and and you know he was like
obviously he was like oh it's about you
know it's for it's for better people to
handle that or
you know it's for other other and i
think one of the things
about him that i feel like i've loved
always
is how how modest he is you know and how
and how
unbelievably grateful like he
really is grateful when something works
it he
really like it 10 years in 11 years how
many years now like
it's like i feel like that child like
exuberance is always there you know you
see the flicker in his eyeballs like as
he lights up and when you're talking
about a character he loves or
hey by the way like they they really
love this like
i think he's in love with what he does
and i think
that's a big part of why you know
there's there's a there's a consistent
passion there
from from him to to to always find
interesting ways to to tell the story
but that that kind of makes sense and
and um i don't know he doesn't get a lot
of credit for that actually i feel like
i thought
one division was a really big [ __ ]
you know like like creative tape you
know
and you know loki's gonna be its own
thing right and
again we existed our tone is very
different because of
we were in the in the tone of the movies
where and
it's a much more grounded way but again
like now we're developing this sort of
buddy comedy aspect to these guys
there there's comedy to this winter
soldier character that never was there
before and
you know i think i think it's always
just um
and and he's he's he's a people's person
he's very um
you know he's surrounded himself with
with the best and i think he
and and his thing is always the best
idea wins
you know there's no ego there man and
and you know that's
a huge huge huge thing so um
yeah maybe that i don't know yeah the
thing about kevin feige is that um
if it was easy to do what he's doing
everyone would do it
well exactly um and that's
that's probably true but i i also feel
like i
like i said i don't my impression is
that there's
nobody's over at that studio you know
getting caught in
um they just love the work you know they
don't get caught in the noise they don't
they
they're not you know they're not as com
they're just always constantly grateful
of like
which is if you look at the movies
they've sort of always done a lot of
the endings of the movies like that is
like well this could be it but maybe
we'll get lucky and we'll get another
one you know it's like there's never
been like well yeah we're gonna
yeah we'll just we're marvel we'll just
[ __ ]
hit another home run like there's always
this
thing of embracing you know
the last film for what it is and and and
the hope of
of of a continuation without expectation
and that's
very difficult to do at that level
they're going to kill me if i keep
talking
all right i'm going to say thank you and
for real man i really enjoyed this movie
no
thank you man all right i'm glad you're
well and you're safe
you too